hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live lange wurde über die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive gesagt sie sei zu langsam
zu viel Verschleiß und es wirkte als
hätten die ukrainischen Truppen kaum
Chancen gegen die breiten
Verteidigungsanlagen die die Russen über
Monate aufgebaut hatten und die von
riesigen Minenfeldern geschützt werden
doch dann ohne Lufthoheit ohne viel mehr
Soldaten zu haben schafft es die Ukraine
sich Meter für Meter vorzukämpfen und
hat im Süden in der Region saporija die
erste Befestigungslinie überwunden und
dann doch wie so oft in diesem
schrecklichen Krieg macht er nicht an
der Frontlinie halt das Grauen geht
weiter im ganzen Land bei einem Angriff
wie diese Bilder hier auch zeigen mit
russischen Drohnen und Raketen in
creveri wurden mehr als 40 Menschen
verletzt eine Polizeistation wurde
getroffen und ein Polizist getötet
und noch ein Raketenangriff
20 Wohnhäuser dabei wurden mindestens
drei Menschen verletzt
wir wollen heute an die Front schauen
unser Thema heute so kämpft sich die
Ukraine vor schaffen Kiews Truppen noch
den entscheidenden Durchbruch das wollen
wir heute besprechen ihr könnt natürlich
Fragen dazu stellen direkt per Mail oder
auch im Stream wir haben uns einen Gast
eingeladen und schalten auch live in die
Ukraine denn unsere Reporter unser
ZDF-Team war unterwegs rund 20 km nur
von der Front entfernt mit einer
Spezialeinheit der ukrainischen Polizei
die gemeinsam mit der ukrainischen Armee
die Offensive vorantreibt dazu später
mehr für die militärische Einordnung ist
nämlich zuerst Ex Nato-General Egon Rams
unserer Gast Luca Simonis und Jonas Kapp
stellen ihn kurz vor
Egon Rams war einer der ranghöchsten
deutschen Nato-Soldaten von 2007 bis
2010 leitete er das NATO Hauptquartier
in brunsum in den Niederlanden dort war
er unter anderem zuständig für die
Einsätze in Afghanistan zuvor war er von
2004 bis 2007 als generalle utnant im
polnischen Stettin stationiert in den
80er und 90er Jahren hatte er
verschiedene Positionen im
Verteidigungsministerium inne Rams ist
Träger mehrerer deutscher und
internationaler Militärorden seit
Russland die Ukraine überfallen hat
analysiert Rams in verschiedenen Medien
die aktuelle Kriegslage
schön dass Sie da sind hallo schönen
guten Abend
schönen guten Abend Frau jung Herr Rams
ich habe es eben schon angesprochen die
erste Befestigungslinie die wurde
überwunden schauen wir auch zusammen auf
eine Karte dann können wir alle
gemeinsam drauf schauen wo wir uns da
örtlich bewegen es geht um die Region in
saporica im Süden der Ukraine sagen sie
das ist nun Grund für Optimismus
also mein Optimismus ist nach wie vor
begrenzt aber ich muss sagen von meinen
Gefühlen her geht es mir besser als vor
14 Tagen denn da zeichnete sich an
solche Erfolg nicht ab und es ist
wichtig dass die erste
Verteidigungslinie überwunden worden ist
weil ich auch davon ausgehe dass die
nachfolgenden auch von den Russen
ausgebauten Verteidigungslinien a von
der Anzahl der Soldaten und B auch von
der Stärke der Befestigung
wahrscheinlich nicht so stark sind wie
die Erste die
im Vorfeld auch Kontakt mit dem
militär-experte Brady afric der
Satellitenaufnahmen entlang der Front
auswertet der hatte uns gesagt dass was
er sieht in diesen Bildern auf diesen
Bildern ist das jetzt danach nachdem
dieser ersten Befestigungslinie in der
zweiten und dritten das ist dadurch
etwas ausgedünnt aussieht was würden Sie
sagen hat Russland genug Material genug
Menschen dass sie genau diese
Verteidigung diese Abwehr da aufrecht
erhalten können wie sie es bislang
gezeigt haben
sei mal wird Russland davon gehe ich aus
in der ersten Verteidigungslinie die
Masse des Personals eingesetzt haben und
wird auch dieses Personal mit
entsprechendem Artilleriefeuer und dem
Einsatz anderer Waffen unterstützt haben
wenn die russische Seite in der ersten
Verteidigungslinie entsprechende
Verluste gehabt hat dann kann es
durchaus sein dass für die zweite und
dritte Linie dann Personal fehlt und das
heißt dass die Linie dann die
nachfolgenlinien dann nicht mehr so
stark besetzt werden können wie ist die
erste war die Verluste werden sich
auswirken und Russland hat glaube ich so
ein bisschen Personalprobleme auch mit
Blick auf die Soldaten obwohl die Russen
insbesondere im Osten also nicht dort wo
wir jetzt drüber reden das Personal
ständig und über den ganzen Sommer hin
verstärkt hat
russische hauptabwehrlinie
auch hatte eben schon gesehen können
auch gleich noch mal drauf schauen die
liegt aktuell südlich von kürzlich
befreiten Ort robotine wie sieht es denn
dort aus wir haben uns das vorzustellen
auf welche Herausforderung trifft die
Ukraine dort
also die ukrainische Truppe wird wenn
Sie diesen Angriff weiter nach Süden
fortsetzt und das davon gehe ich aus
wird sie tun
wieder erneut auf große Minenfelder
wieder erneut auf die zweite
möglicherweise dritte russische
Verteidigungslinie und der Kampf wird
für die Ukraine in ähnliche Art und
Weise weitergehen bis die Durchbrüche
entsprechend erweitert werden und die
Ukraine dann auch die Möglichkeit haben
nach Überwinden der Minenfeldern dann
entsprechend ihre schweren Waffen
einzusetzen es gibt eine erste Frage aus
dem Stream von User Mario er schreibt
ist das Wunschdenken dass die Ukraine
kurz vor dem Durchbruch steht oder was
spricht wirklich dafür
also ich teile diese Auffassung in
gewisse Art und Weise ich sag dir ich
bin etwas optimistischer als vor 14
Tagen dieser erste Durchbruch bei
opportine ist ein erster Erfolg und es
geht jetzt für die Ukraine darum mit
entsprechenden Einsatz von Soldaten aber
auch von Material diesen Durchbruch oder
diesen ersten Durchbruch entsprechend
auszuweiten ich glaube das in den
letzten Wochen in den Medien sehr viel
von der stockenden Großoffensive
berichtet worden ist so dass das Risiko
dass dieses jetzt zu einer Art
Wunschdenken wird dass es jetzt zügig
voran geht relativ groß ist also wir
sollten in den nächsten Tagen nächsten
Wochen sehr sorgfältig das beobachten
und abwarten wie sich die Lage dort
weiterentwickelt und ich möchte dazu
auch keine Vorhersage machen weil ich
dazu nicht in der Lage bin wir haben
eben gerade als sie auch geantwortet
haben noch mal die detaillierte Karte
gesehen denn weiter südlich von dem
befreiten Ort von robertinnen liegt der
Ort talkmack geht als strategisch
wichtig auch auf dem Weg zum Meer
theoretisch natürlich wenn man dadurch
käme wie viel Gelände müsste man hier
denn zurückerobern müsste man die Stadt
Talk mag wirklich zurückerobern um einen
Erfolg zu erzielen
ist ein strategisch wichtiger Punkt weil
sich dort viele straßenkreuzen auch eine
Eisenbahnlinie in der Nähe vorbei geht
das heißt aber nicht dass man dann die
Ortschaft Tokmak entsprechend erobern
muss man kann auch topmarkt wenn das
geht einkesseln und kann möglicherweise
diese Ortschaft auch mit Feuer
beherrschen ich weiß nicht welche
Planung die Ukraine in dieser Richtung
hat das bleibt abzuwarten wieder und
wird sich in den nächsten Wochen sage
ich mal vorsichtigerweise entscheiden
wie die Ukraine dort weitergehen wird
Norbert Kranz möchte gerne dazu wissen
jetzt können die Ukrainer die Linien
doch von den Seiten aufrollen und den
Durchbruch weiter ausweiten oder
also wenn die Ukraine die Möglichkeit
haben beispielsweise Minen Sperren zu
umgehen und in die
Verteidigungsstellungen nicht von
frontalanzug greifen sondern von den
Seiten der anzugreifen dann werden sie
das sicher machen der ukrainische
Generalstab aber auch die örtlichen
Kommandeure der ukrainische Streitkräfte
haben eigentlich in den zurückliegenden
fast anderthalb Jahren unter Beweis
gestellt dass sie in der Lage sind die
Gunst einer bestimmten Situation für
sich auszunutzen und ich gehe davon aus
dass sie das auch weitermachen werden
ich möchte aber ein kleines aber dahin
hängen wenn wir sehen wie die Russen im
vergangenen Jahr nach der Umgruppierung
der Kräfte in den Osten also etwa ab
April Mai im Osten agiert haben dann
müssen wir auch feststellen dass die
russischen die russische Führung
offensichtlichen diesen zurückliegenden
Vierteljahr auch gewaltig dazugelernt
hat das heißt die russische Seite hat
eine Lernkurve gemacht die
möglicherweise auch den Russen erlaubt
dann die entsprechenden Gegenreaktionen
zu ergreifen und auch dieses bleibt
abzuwarten ob sich das so entwickeln
wird und ob die Ukrainer tatsächlich
wieder wie im vergangenen Jahr einen
taktischen Vorteile bringen können
ja wie eine Art Keil in die russische
Befestigungslinie getrieben gibt's da
nicht auch die Sorge dass man dann von
den Flanken wenn man sich das bildlich
vorstellt auch wieder angegriffen werden
könnte
ja das ist ein wichtiger Punkt den sie
da ansprechen wenn ich tief in die
feindlichen Linien Eindrücke eindringe
kann ich auch von den Flanken aus durch
den Feind entsprechend bekämpft werden
es eine ganz allgemeine Regel das heißt
die Ukraine kann jetzt nicht nur nach
vorne gucken sprich nach Süden gucken
sondern sie muss auch nach Westen und
sie muss auch nach Osten gucken um zu
vermeiden dass die Flanken Angriffe der
russischen Kräfte in ihre Seiten rein
bekommt und dann möglicherweise auch
Truppenteile abgeschnitten werden bzw
durch diese Flanken Angriffe sich in
verschiedenen Richtungen verteidigen
müssen was dann auch deutlich mehr
Kräfte erfordert
sprechen wir genau das Thema an Kräfte
sowohl Menschen als auch Material ich
sehe hier einen Kommentar bei Youtube da
schreibt jemand mal sehen wer die
größeren Reserven hat die Ukraine hat
mit der Offensive zu viele Soldaten
geopfert es wird ihr für den
langfristigen Erfolg zum Problem so die
Meinung eines Users und eine Frage steht
auch noch mit im Stream und zwar möchte
ich hier der User Dennis wissen wann
wird die Ukraine die zurückgehaltenen
Panzerbataillon voll in den Einsatz
bringen können wenn wir uns jetzt mal
das Material was die Ukraine hat genauer
anschauen
also ich fange mal mit dem mit dem Thema
der schweren Waffen an und wie man die
einsetzen kann diese schweren Waffen
werden erst dann zum Einsatz kommen
können wenn Minenfelder in größerer Zahl
entweder beseitigt geräumt oder
gesprengt worden sind weil sonst die
Panzer im Prinzip wie auf einer Linie
einer hinter dem anderen fahren und
damit natürlich für die russische Seite
leichte Ziele werden das heißt die
Angriffe müssen breiter gemacht werden
und das verlangt dass die russische
verteilungslinie nach Osten und nach
Westen noch ein deutlicher Maße weiter
bekämpft wird um auf diese Art und Weise
schwere Waffen auch zum Einsatz bringen
zu können das sage ich dir wichtige Teil
dabei zu dem Thema Personal und
Ausrüstung ja es ist richtig dass auch
die Ukraine erhebliche Verlust gehabt
hat auch beim Personal aber ich erlaube
mir den Hinweis dass auch die russische
Seite Personal Probleme hat man hat ja
das Alter für die Wehrpflicht aufgesetzt
und wieder neues Personal rekrutieren zu
können und das ist ein Zeichen dafür
dass Russland ebenfalls personelle
Probleme hat dass der eine Punkt neu und
der zweite Punkt dabei ist dass die
ukrainischen Soldaten die ukrainischen
zuchtführer Kompaniechefs und
bataillonskommandeure ihre Soldaten
wesentlich ich sage das mal Personal
schonender einsetzen und darauf achten
dass Ihre Verluste nicht zu hoch sind
das ist auf der russischen Seite bisher
noch nicht wahrzunehmen von daher hat
hinsichtlich der Verluste an Menschen
die Ukraine ein eindeutigen Vorteil bei
Material sieht das möglicherweise etwas
anders aus und ich muss da deutlich den
Punkt machen die Ukraine hängt von der
Unterstützung aus den westlichen Ländern
ab und ich nehme nur als Beispiel das
Thema Kampfpanzer Leopard 1 A5 das erste
Mal öffentlich erwähnt am 18.09
vergangenen Jahres bei einer Talkshow
die Entscheidung diesen Panzer abzugeben
sind gefallen Januar Februar und wenn
man Kenntnisstand richtiges aber bisher
zehn von denen geliefert und das ist
eigentlich deutlich zu wenig das heißt
in diesem Bereich leidet die Ukraine in
Not die im Prinzip nur dann abgemildert
werden kann wenn wir wissen Star
schnelle Entscheidung fällen und dann
auch mit den entsprechenden Mitteln
dafür sorgen durch Instandsetzung
beispielsweise dass diese Entscheidung
auch entsprechend schnell umgesetzt
werden ich sage das ganz offen das geht
mir bisweilen oder auch in der heutigen
Zeit immer noch zu langsam ein weiter
wie ein weiterer wichtiger Punkt in
diesem Krieg die Ukraine hat keine
Lufthoheit setzt aber immer mehr Drohnen
auch selbst gebaute Drohnen ein darüber
hatten wir auch letzte Woche Freitag in
unserem Stream berichtet wie schätzen
Sie das ein welchen Fortschritt lässt
sich machen mit diesem Einsatz der
Drohnen eben auch der selbstgebauten
Drohnen
also die selbstgebauten drohten Drohnen
sind ein Punkt der mich in den letzten
anderthalb Jahren etwas erstaunt hat
denn die Ukraine hat in diese Richtung
was die was die Herstellung ich sage
auch mal das Thema Forschung die
Entwicklung und den Produktion dieser
Drohnen angeht auch einen gewaltigen Weg
nach vorne gemacht sie nutzt diese
Drohnen nach meinem Kind entstand sehr
geschickt zum Teil auch weitreichender
Drohnen wobei ich da nicht immer weiß ob
da nicht auch Fake Nachrichten und Fake
News von der russischen Seite mit bei
sind wenn wir über die Angriffe auf
Moskau reden trotzdem die Ukraine setzt
diese Drohnen geschickt ein und auch für
ich sag das mal Aufklärung und
Bekämpfung der russischen Truppen und
sie ist da drin sehr geschickt
sie stehen uns gleich noch für weitere
Analysen zur Verfügung wir wollen aber
jetzt wie auch am Anfang der Sendung
angekündigt in die Ukraine schalten wir
können nämlich sprechen mit unserem
Korrespondenten vor Ort in saporisa in
der Hebestreit ist bei uns und wir sagen
erstmal hallo schön dass du da bist
hallo Hanna
du warst unterwegs mit einer
Spezialeinheit der ukrainischen Polizei
die eben gemeinsam mit der Armee dort zu
Gange ist in der Region saporisa in der
Nähe von urichif und wir schauen jetzt
mal kurz zusammen erst in deinen Beitrag
und hören dann von dir weitere
Schilderungen
abgeschirmt durch einen Vorhang der vor
allem gegen die allgegenwärtigen fliegen
schützen soll statt Reka so seinen
kampfname auf Monitore sie zeigen in
Echtzeit was an der Front bei SAP vor
sich geht seit Wochen wertet er
stundenlang solche drohnenbilder aus
wir haben den Krieg wirklich satt aber
wenn wir einfach die Hände in den Schoß
legen wird es ja nicht besser
ich kann nur sagen dass es mir so geht
dass ich meinen Rhythmus gefunden habe
man hört einfach auf die Erschöpfung zu
spüren man arbeitet weiter wie eine
Maschine
die Soldaten hier draußen erzählen wie
schwer es nach Beginn der ukrainischen
Gegenoffensive war den Durchbruch durch
die russischen Linien zu schaffen
das Problem ist das schwere
Artilleriefeuer sobald du anfängst
voranzukommen fliegt sofort alles auf
dich zu man muss warten bis sich der
Beschuss etwas beruhigt hat aber der
Feind nutzt dann die Zeit sich neu
aufzustellen das macht alles so
schwierig
sie können überhaupt nicht sagen wann
die Gegend Offensive ihr Ziel erreicht
haben könnte zu viele Faktoren spielen
eine Rolle
ich kann ihnen nicht mal sagen welche
das sind aber einer ist zum Beispiel das
Wetter wenn es morgen anfängt zu regnen
kann es leicht passieren dass die
Offensive eine Woche auf Eis gelegt wird
sie werden sicher noch eine ganze Weile
hier sitzen und auf die drohnenbilder
starren um zu sehen was die Gegner an
der Front gerade machen
eine Einheit die drohnenbilder auswertet
was haben sie dir berichtet was das
aktuell die größte Herausforderung für
diese Truppe
die größte Herausforderung ist natürlich
das Material sie haben viel Material
verschlissen und auch wenn Sie moderne
Panzer in der Gegend sind auch Leopard 2
wie wir hören im Einsatz auch diese
werden von Panzerminen getroffen gehen
kaputt müssen repariert werden also sie
brauchen Nachschub was wir auch hören
ist das die Munition ein Problem ist man
schießt dort offenbar mit mit Artillerie
Granaten aus den 50er Jahren die sagen
das ist altes altes Material die sind
nicht im wahrsten Sinn des Wortes nicht
dicht das Pulver tritt an irgendeiner
Seite aus so wurde mir das geschieden
ich kann das persönlich nicht beurteilen
die sagen nur wir müssen dann 10 11 12
mal auf das gleiche Ziel schießen wenn
wir ordentliche frische neue Munition
haben dann reichen zwei drei Treffer aus
und wir haben das Ziel zerstört so sagen
sie uns und da haben sie wirklich
erheblichen Bedarf und das sind die
Ressourcen der Russen offenbar deutlich
größer
und wir haben auch gehört so viele
Faktoren die natürlich den Erfolg oder
Misserfolg beeinflussen so z.B auch das
Wetter wie sehr fürchten die Soldaten
denn den sich langsam aber trotzdem
nähernden Herbst Winter und das dann
eben vielleicht nichts mehr weitergeht
na das fürchten sie schon also wir
merken das auch selber bis vor ein zwei
Tagen war das hier noch sehr warm und
jetzt ist es doch um diese Zeit wir
haben es hier eine Stunde später als bei
euch schon sehr frisch geworden
wir haben mit Leuten gesprochen die
sagen wir sitzen in irgendwelchen
Stellungen das sind meistens beschädigte
Häuser weil sie da drin nicht vermutet
werden irgendwo in der Nähe der Front
und und machen da unsere
Aufklärungsarbeit und da sitzt man drei
vier Tage und im Sommer ist das eine
Geschichte wenn es aber die ganze Zeit
regnet werden sie sagten sie uns richtig
krank da kriegt auch einen ein
ukrainischer Soldat ein ukrainischer
Polizist irgendwie Schnupfen und Grippe
und fällt dann eben aus die sagen so wie
der Regen anfängt so wie das Wetter
umschlägt ist ihre Meinung nach die
Offensive zum Stillstand verurteilt und
dann wird es eine ganze Zeit dauern bis
es wieder losgeht da sind wir dann schon
im nächsten Jahr
sie beobachten eben das haben wir in
deinem Beitrag ja auch gehört und
gesehen also Bilder in Echtzeit von der
Frontlinie haben sie dann auch ein
bisschen Hoffnung dass uns eben im
ersten Teil der Sendung schon
angesprochen dass also jetzt an der
zweiten und dritten Linie sie vielleicht
eben auf weniger Widerstand stoßen
ja also wir konnten das das ist ja
völlig bizarren man steht da und guckt
in Echtzeit auch irgend so ein
Schützengraben der sechs sieben acht
Kilometer entfernt ist und sieht da die
Leute von links nach rechts durchs Bild
laufen und dann hört man ja wir haben da
jetzt schon seit Stunden drauf geguckt
oder seit Tagen drauf geguckt wir
versuchen rauszukriegen wie viele Leute
dort in diesem Graben sind dann wird ab
und zu mal drauf geschossen um zu sehen
wie sind die Reaktionen und dann wird
irgendwann beschlossen dass man da auch
mal militärisch aktiv wird und diesen
Graben zu heben also das ist
das ist alles irgendwie völlig so real
ich will jetzt nicht wieder dieses alte
Bild vom vom Videospiel bemühen aber wir
haben auch den ähm den Anführer dieser
Kompanie gefragt immer wie geht ihr denn
damit um wenn ihr seht ich meine wir
kennen ja diese Bilder alle aus dem Netz
da fliegt von so einer Drohne so eine
kleine Granate runter und unten sieht
man dann wie ein zwei drei gegnerische
Soldaten dann dazu tote kommen
das naja wir sind jetzt nicht mehr im
Zivil leben wir sind Militärs und wenn
wir anfangen uns solche Gedanken zu
machen wenn wir Emotionen damit
reinbringen das ist unsere größte
verändern dann können wir nicht mehr
klar denken also das ist alles eine
Situation das ist äh ein Krieg der in
Echtzeit vor lauter Kameras stattfindet
und wie das dann weitergehen wird ob das
große Schritte werden ob das kleine
Schritte werden das wird dann
wahrscheinlich erst dann sehen oder es
werden die ukrainischen Kräfte dann
sehen wenn sie wirklich vor den
Stellungen stehen was sich denn da
abspielen spielt was dort tatsächlich
auf sie wartet Eindrücke von Hanna
Hebestreit live aus der Politiker vielen
Dank
und bei uns ist jetzt auch noch einmal
ex-natogan general Egon Rams mit dem wir
jetzt noch weiter in die Analyse
einsteigen können auch noch ein bisschen
noch Zeit für eure Fragen ich habe ein
Auge drauf wir haben eben gerade die
Schilderungen von Hannah Hebestreit
gehört vielleicht schauen wir jetzt auch
erst ein bisschen zurück und dann nach
vorne das wäre wahrscheinlich auch
spannend vielleicht erstmal um über die
Taktik der Ukrainer noch mal zu sprechen
die kommt ja vermutlich nicht aus einem
NATO Lehrbuch wie bewerten sie denn die
Taktik der letzten Wochen und Monate was
hat sich als positiv erwiesen wo gab es
vielleicht Fehler und hohe
Materialverluste
also die Taktik der Ukrainer war im
vergangenen Jahr und da möchte ich gerne
anfangen eine sehr geschickte weil sie
immer wieder mit kleinen
Anzahl von Soldaten ich sage mal Gruppen
und zustärke also 10 oder 30 Leute die
Stellung beispielsweise im Osten aber
auch im Raum Casino der russischen Seite
aufgerollt haben man hatte
offensichtlich zu Beginn dieser
Gegenoffensive vor mit einem breiteren
Ansatz mit Kampfpanzern und
Schützenpanzern vorzugehen und ist dabei
zum Teil in Minensperren reingelaufen
die diese Angriffe gestoppt haben und
die auch Verluste an Menschen Gott sei
Dank relativ wenig aber auch Material
verursacht haben es gab Bilder im Netz
wo man sehen konnte wie sieben
Schützenpanzer Bradley ihre Kette
verloren haben einer von denen brannte
dabei war auch ein Kampfpanzer Leopard
und ein Panzer der vermutlich dieser
verstärkten Kompanie vorausgefahren ist
um eine Minensperre zu räumen sie sind
alle in den Minenfeld liegen geblieben
worauf sich die ukrainische Seite dann
wieder entschlossen
mit kleineren Einheiten und mit
Infanterie vorzugehen was natürlich
zeitaufwendiger ist und B dann
möglicherweise auch für die Soldaten
erhebliche Verluste bedeutet weil sie
Zeit brauchen ist der eine Teil dabei
aber auch halt eben nicht unter
Panzerschutz vorgehen können erst wenn
diese Minenfelder tatsächlich freigelegt
sind oder geräumt sind oder man wie der
eine User vorhin gesagt hat von den
Flanken an diesem Minenfelder rangehen
kann oder über die mühlenfelder
hinweggehen kann hat man möglicherweise
eine Chance die Angriffsgeschwindigkeit
zu erhöhen das Wasser Hebestreit gerade
gesagt hat ist entsprechend zutreffend
ist auch zutriff mit Blick auf die
Emotionen der Soldaten wobei ich glaube
dass die ukrainischen Soldaten
mittlerweile über so viel Kampf
Erfahrung verfügen auch Soldaten die neu
dazukommen durch ältere Kameraden
entsprechend dann in diese Situation
reingestellt und entsprechend
unterstützt werden dass die ukrainische
Soldaten von der Seite her ich glaube
keine emotionalen Verluste haben wobei
auch das ist ein Thema welches
möglicherweise irgendwann während des
Krieges oder nach dem Krieg hinsichtlich
psychothromatischer Störungen nochmal
aufgearbeitet werden muss schauen wir
auch noch einmal auf die russische Seite
und ein User habe ich gesehen hat viele
Fragen gestellt ich möchte eine
rausgreifen icke bei Youtube möchte
wissen was kann die internationale
Gemeinschaft noch tun um die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive noch in diesem Jahr zum
entscheidenden Erfolg zu führen das war
die eine Frage wobei seine zweite schon
auch war dass wir noch mal auf den
Verschleiß der russischen Armee schauen
machen wir das zuerst schauen uns die
russische Seite an und kommen dann zu
dem part was kann die internationale
Gemeinschaft tun was glauben Sie wie
sieht es aus auf der russischen Seite
also fest steht dass die russische Seite
eine erheblich höheren Anteil an
Verlusten sowohl bei Menschen als auch
bei Material gehabt hat als es die
ukrainische Seite gab da die Russen
haben sage ich mal zumindest im ersten
Kriegs ja ein Verschleiß Krieg geführt
ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste in den
eigenen Reihen an Mensch und Material
von daher ist auch die materielle
Überlegenheit der Russen nicht mehr so
groß die Aussage gilt zum Teil auch für
Munition von daher dort liegt eine
Chance der Ukraine und jetzt kommt
wieder die Kondition wenn der Westen
seine Waffenlieferung aufrichtet und
dafür sorgt dass die Ukraine in dieser
Beziehung Gefecht sind kampffähig bleibt
lange Prozesse der Entscheidungen lange
lieferprozesse und dergleichen oder
lange instandsetzungsprozesse sind dabei
nicht von Vorteil für die Ukraine
zu der ersten Frage ob die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive dieses Jahr noch Erfolg
hat Frau jung das ist eine Frage die
kann ich nicht beantworten es tut mir
leid ich würde es den Ukrainern wünschen
ich würde mich darüber freuen wenn sie
tatsächlich irgendwann in eine Situation
versetzt würden wo sie Raum greifender
Angriffe durchführen können Richtung
Meer und auf diese Art und Weise den
Anteil der Krim aber auch Verkehrslinien
Verkehrsknotenpunkte und dergleichen
mehr für die Russen nicht mehr nutzbar
zu machen denn das wäre der Weg den die
Ukraine zum Teil letztes Jahr und in der
Tiefe des Raumes auch schon gegangen ist
die Logistik auszuhungern und auf diese
Art und Weise dann auch die
entsprechenden Konsequenzen bei den
Russen zu verursachen aber ich
wiederhole eine Vorhersage traue ich mir
diesbezüglich was die Zeiten angeht
nicht zu
ja die Frage die stand auch so ein
bisschen im Zusammenhang da möchte ich
gerne noch eine weitere anschließen was
müsste der besten tun was müsste aus dem
Westen kommen Simon Feld kam fragt sich
nämlich welche Voraussetzungen müssen
geschaffen werden damit Taurus
Marschflugkörper geliefert werden wir
erinnern uns da wurde ja schon öfter
darüber diskutiert er schreibt noch
weiter könnte sein dass man der Ukraine
zutraut bis zur Krim ohne diese
überhaupt durchzustoßen wie sehr braucht
es also vielleicht für einen Erfolg die
Taurus Marschflugkörper
Marschflugkörper könnten beispielsweise
auf entsprechende Entfernung auf die
Krim wirken aber das kann man auch mit
anderen Waffen erreichen beispielsweise
mit den berühmten Heimat Raketenwerfern
der Amerikaner und dafür ist nach meinem
Kenntnisstand genügend Munition da von
daher das ist nicht unbedingt Taurus
aber Taurus ist eine Waffe die in die
Tiefe des Raumes wirken kann mit einer
Reichweite von 500 km Plus von daher
würde das die Qualität bei bestimmten
Dingen schon verändern und die
Diskussionen die zurzeit bei uns in
Deutschland geführt wird ob man den
Ukrainer dafür die Waffen geben darf und
sich auf das Wort der Ukraine die nicht
auf russischen Boden einzusetzen
verlassen soll oder ob man sich
technischreibt weißen mäßig begrenzt das
ist eine Diskussion die halte ich ein
bisschen für irrational wenn man den
Ukraine wirklich alles geben sollte was
ihnen hilft diesen Krieg erfolgreich
weiter vorzuführen was ja auch in
unserem Interesse ist denn wir müssen
immer daran denken dass auch unsere
Freiheit Rechtsstaatlichkeit
Menschenrechte durch die ukrainische
Soldaten um die ukrainische
Zivilbevölkerung in der Ukraine
verteidigt werden und wie das weitergeht
wenn Putin Erfolg hat ist ebenfalls eine
Vorhersage die ich nicht machen kann wo
aber aus meiner ehemaligen
Wirkungsstätte Polen oder beispielsweise
aus dem baltischen Staaten die
Befürchtungen in diese Richtung doch
relativ groß sind das ist ein Grund
warum die genannten Länder in den
letzten Tagen wieder entschieden haben
ihre Unterstützung für die Ukraine
finanziell aber auch waffenmäßig weiter
zu intensivieren und vorzusetzen das
gleiche würde ich mir auch von anderen
Wünschen und schauen wir jetzt nach
vorne schauen wir auf es wird passieren
natürlich irgendwann der Wetterumschwung
den Herbst zunächst einmal natürlich
welche Herausforderungen bieten sich
dann oder stellen sich da in dem Gebiet
in der Region saporiza wo eben aktuell
so heftig gekämpft wird
also dieser Raum südlich von robertine
ist ein Raum der sehr tief liegt fast
auf Höhe des Meeresspiegels der der
Schwarzen Meeres und der nur nach Osten
eine höhenschwelle hat und nach Westen
allerdings weit weg eine höhenschwelle
hat das heißt er hat eine Wirkung wie
eine Schüssel wenn wir starke Regenfälle
kriegen dann läuft dieses Gebiet
durchzogen von vielen Flüssen durchzogen
von vielen Gräben teilweise Sumpfgebiete
schlicht und einfach voll und dann kommt
praktisch jede Bewegung mehr oder
weniger zum Stillstand das wäre eine
ausgesprochen ungünstige Situation und
würde dann auch in der Konsequenz
bedeuten dass der Krieg im Prinzip im
nächsten Jahr weiter fortgeführt wird
mit Ausnahme der Bewegung die vielleicht
noch ermöglicht werden können wenn man
starken Frost hat aber auch da muss man
dann abwarten wie das Wetter weitermacht
das heißt man wird stark abhängig von
den Witterungsbedingungen und das ist
dann die möglicherweise für die Ukrainer
in einigen Bereichen nicht von Vorteil
während die Russen dann in ihre
Verteidigungsstellungen sicherlich auch
kein komfortables Leben haben aber dort
halt eben den Witterungsbedingungen
nicht so ausgesetzt sind wie du keiner
die sich in diesem Gelände bewegen
müssen und sie sprechen es an die
russische Seite also womit muss man
vielleicht rechnen dann jetzt auch in
den nächsten Monaten wenn das so kommen
sollte muss man damit rechnen dass ich
auch die Russen wieder versuchen mehr
einzugraben oder ist das eben auch im
Winter gar nicht denkbar was glauben Sie
was was dazu erwarten ist
also wenn sie starken Bodenfrost haben
wird das mit dem Eingabe ein bisschen
schwierig wenn sie starken Reben haben
auch weil ihn dann die gegrabenen
Schützengräben volllaufen mit Wasser das
ist dann für die Soldaten die dort
verteidigen sollen auch nicht unbedingt
eine angenehme Situation und dann gilt
das was vorhin gesagt worden ist vom
Thema Erkältung auf die ukrainischen
Soldaten in gleicher Art und Weise auch
für die russischen Soldaten da muss man
einfach darauf hinweisen trotzdem hat
der Verteidiger in einer solchen
Situation hat er Vorteile wenn der
Angreifer sich nicht mehr bewegen kann
weil das Gelände und das Wetter ist
nicht mehr zulassen dann wird die Sache
für die Ukraine schwieriger und da haben
die Russen möglicherweise Vorteile
vielleicht noch eine weitere Anmerkung
dazu die Russen haben offensichtlich
ihren Schwerpunkt in den Osten gelegt
sie versuchen ja auch dort wieder
Richtung andere Bereichen Raum Gewinne
zu erreichen und ich vermute das muss
ich allerdings auch so sagen ohne zu
spekulieren dass die Kräfte die im Süden
angesetzt sind dann nicht ausreichen
werden auf der russischen Seite wenn die
Ukraine tatsächlich die Möglichkeit hier
Angriffe erfolgreich vorzusetzen was wie
ich vorhin gesagt habe auch von uns
abhängt ich möchte einen Hinweis geben
Thema Luftüberlegenheit der russischen
Seite ja das ist der Grund warum die
Ukraine so intensiv nach den F16 fragt
ist es aber auch positiv zu vermerken
dass in den letzten in der letzten Woche
die ersten großen Lieferungen an
Munition für den Flakpanzer Geppert
beispielsweise geliefert worden sind und
damit die Luftverteidigung mit dem
Flakpanzer Geppert gestärkt werden kann
ein weiterer positiver Punkt ist ihres
SLM ihres slrteile ausgesprochen hohe
abschlussquadquote aber auch dort
verfügt die ureine und keine bisher nur
über zwei Batterien und es soll noch
welche geliefert werden ich kann nur
sagen ich hoffe dass die bald kommen um
auch diese Luft Überlegenheit
auszugleichen F16 werden wir glaube ich
in diesem Jahr in der Ukraine nicht mehr
sehen das heißt da müssen wir uns dann
auf das nächste Jahr konzentrieren
neben der Moral der Truppe ist natürlich
auch noch ein weiterer Punkt wichtig
dass Durchhaltevermögen und auch die
Unterstützung aus der Bevölkerung der
Ukraine die natürlich Monat für Monat
mit heftigen Angriffen auch jenseits der
Frontlinie zu kämpfen hat wir schätzen
sie das ein die Unterstützung aus dem
Land hält die weiter an
also ich glaube dass der ukrainische
Präsident selensky sehr stark daran
arbeitet dass diese Unterstützung der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung nicht nachlässt
dafür gibt es auch im Prinzip einen
Beleg es hat Ende August oder mitte ende
August eine Meinungsumfrage bei 2000
repräsentativen Menschen in der Ukraine
stattgefunden und dort kommt eindeutig
zum Ausdruck dass drei Viertel der
Menschen dafür sind dass die Ukraine
sich weiter verteidigt dass 90% der
Menschen keinen Land der Ukraine an
Russland abgeben wollen von daher das
ist eine ausgesprochen positive
Situation die dort ist die natürlich
durch die Angriffe auch von Drohnen
marschlugkörpern in der Tiefe des Landes
beeinflusst wird aber auch dort zeigt
die ukrainische Bevölkerung bisher sehr
viel Moral und es sieht nach diesen
Meinungsumfragen und nachdem was man
berichten hört so aus dass die
ukrainische Bevölkerung weiter hinter
ihrem Truppen hinter ihren Soldaten
steht und die Regierung entsprechend
unterstützen
die Analyse von Ex Nato-General Egon
Rams vielen Dank dass Sie heute Abend
bei uns zu Gast waren
ich habe zu danken
und ihr könnt natürlich auch weiterhin
bei uns im wöchentlichen Turnus auch
eine Ukraine Analyse bei uns hier
erwarten immer wieder gerne dann auch
eure Fragen stellen für heute sage ich
erstmal vielen Dank dafür und wir alle
aus dem Team wünschen euch ein schönes
Wochenende bis zum nächsten Mal gerne
tschüss